bonsoir ce soir édition spéciale une
série de meurtres violents qui ont
choqué la
nation je m'appelleen Mendel et je suis
tuur en série qu'est-ce que tu
fais prochainement tu es en
série je m'appelle Norman GRM je suis
réalisateur de documentaire alors quand
je suis tombé sur
mend je savais que j'avais trouvé le
sujet de ma prochaine histoire on va
fonder une famille wouh comme Charles
Monson l'idée d'être chef d'une secte
m'a toujours attiré pourquoi voulez-vous
rejoindre notre famille les meurtres la
drogue le
[Musique]
sexe je
ici apprendre alors vous êtes ici au bon
endroit mon ami c'est
certain bienvenue au camp d'entraînement
de la famille Mendel et bienvenue au
cours d'introduction des armes le plan
c'est que la famille trouve une maison
pour le meurtre entrer par
rraction alors ce soir on va commettre
nos premiers meurtres pourquoi tu ne
viens pas avec nous et bien je vais tout
coordonner
d'ici tuer les
[Musique]
tous ils le font vraiment des gens se
font vraiment tuer on va rentrer dans
l'histoire du cinéma cette soirée marque
le début de ma carrière de tueur
série tu n'es pas un tueur en série non
c'est faux pour l'instant tu n'as encore
tué personne je vais finir ce
documentaire avec un vrai
[Musique]
tueur un petit
four on dirait que vous allez bien me
voir tuer quelqu'un
[Musique]
finalement